even by modern American political
standards Anna even by um the standards
of what we've seen over the course of
the past extraordinary week as they
tried to elect a speaker the past few
hours have been utterly extraordinary it
is still unfolding uh in the chamber of
the House of Representatives it was only
a few moments ago that um Kevin McCarthy
was confirmed after as you say 15 rounds
of boating that stretches back four days
he was confirmed as the third most
powerful politician in America second in
line to the presidency after the Vice
President the speaker of the U.S House
of Representatives
um this uh a day has as I say taken four
days you have to go back well over a
century to find a period of time where
it has taken this long for Congress to
elect a speaker
um we say I say it was extraordinary the
past few hours but because
the what we saw unfolding about an hour
and a half ago was the expectation by
Kevin McCarthy that he would win the
vote after the on the 14th round his
people had done the maths they'd worked
out that he'd got the votes a small
ultra-conservative grouping of the
Republican Party had up until that point
been blocking his appointment but he
reckoned he'd got it then but Matt Gates
a Ultra conservative highly
controversial Fringe politician decided
not to vote with him then we saw these
extraordinary images and I hope we can
show them to you of uh Kevin McCarthy
marching through the chamber up to
confront Matt Gates and to to ask him
here it is ask him why he didn't vote
with him very very angry you can see
Kevin McCarthy there as the camera pans
out uh Matt Gates is there sitting down
in the gray suit these two have a a
conversation uh for a period of time
time and remember that over the course
of the past 14 votes Uh Kevin McCarthy
has been conceding to these Fringe
politicians to get them to vote with him
giving them all sorts of concessions
which will become clear over the course
of the next few hours I would think and
we'll probably put Kevin McCarthy in
somewhat of a straight jacket in terms
of his ability to be able to govern as
leader NOW Watch What Happens Next as
they're talking someone comes I hope we
got this image as well someone comes
from the back another Congressman Mike
Rogers who tries also to have a word
with um Matt Gates and as he does he is
pulled away forcibly pulled away by
another Republican remember as you're
looking at these pictures this isn't
left work versus right this isn't the
the left of politics clashing as they do
in every country with the right of
politics what we watched there is right
on right Blue on Blue uh or in this case
red on red because they it is exposing
deep divisions within the Republican
party so we've got there after um 15
rounds of voting
um but it is very very messy I I hope
we've got the um the image of of the
restraining that took place
um we've also got another interesting
image which is um a phone being held by
uh Marjorie Taylor green who is a
um conspiracy theorist another very
controversial Fringe figure even within
her own party DT it says on that phone
Donald Trump a man who is still pulling
the strings or at least trying to uh
within uh the uh with it within the
Chamber of the House of Representatives